hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast laboratory role and diagnosis
of antiphospholipid antibodies in
antiphospholipid syndrome presented by
vladimir viduh Novick assistant
professor of clinical pathology
University of illinois-chicago I'm
Alexis Krause of labyrinth and I'll be
our moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by laberd's
laberd's is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop down box that
appears on the screen our speaker will
spawn to your questions via email if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and followed the
process to obtain your credits please
join me in welcoming dr. Vera Novick I
will now turn the presentation over to
him good morning everyone so my main
objective today is deliver to deliver
succeeds but hopefully clarifying
presentation which would explain the
physiological role of phospholipids in
normal hemostasis then the proposed
pathophysiological mechanisms
information of antiphospholipid
antibodies which often lead to
antiphospholipid syndrome then we can go
over current diagnostic criteria for
entered phospholipid syndrome including
the basis for laboratory determination
of those
the bodies in finally to mention
challenges in obtaining accurate
diagnosis besides many abbreviations in
the literature I would say you are
seeing antiphospholipid antibodies a PR
literature a PS or APA lupus
anticoagulant then antiphospholipid
syndrome it can be written as a PS or
APL versus lupus anticoagulant syndrome
so there are many many acronyms Hewes
syndrome if we detect an taqueria lip in
antibodies which which could be detected
in antiphospholipid antibody syndrome
they can be abbreviated as a CA or a CLA
like anti cardiolipin antibodies versus
small a CL so it's really it could be
exhausting going to this laundry list of
abbreviations but I would say that the
most commonly used name is lupus
anticoagulant which is a paradox this is
the most inept in the most inaccurate
the scripture of this clinically
heterogeneous condition since it is
neither always associated with lupus nor
these antibodies exert any anticoagulant
effect the matter of fact we all know
that lupus anticoagulant cost Ramos's
they do not cause bleeding so this is
not anticoagulant and that regular thing
will explain this later White's going to
coagulant because it's prolonging some
clarabelle coagulation assays they're
calling it anticoagulant although this
is not
anticoagulant but again even among
clinicians I see them this is commonly
news named lupus anticoagulant is gonna
be very difficult to kind of change the
culture maybe not to use that name so
I'm gonna also speak with Lou percent
accredited a in this presentation often
but at least this explanation will
explain to you why hate the name
to center graduate we're going to the
next slide the NH site provides very
nice in the layman's terms explain the
nature of this disease its demographics
then the last sentence of this slide
exemplifies and still existing
conceptual conundrum in understanding
the sequence of events in and around and
two trillion cells when the chicken and
the egg causality dilemma whether
antibodies against phospholipids come
first or they're generated as an as an
immune response to a few epitopes in
cellular membranes so still there is a
dilemma whether cladding comes as a
result of something happening on the
period or previously form antibodies
will wreak havoc on that endothelial
service surface causing formation of
term drawn by and enter possibly be
changer important facts from that site
that could be remembered that this is an
autoimmune disorder can affect people of
any age it's slightly more common in
women but it affects both sexes and it's
more commonly people who have other
autoimmune or rheumatic disorders so
that's why I has the name lupus
anticoagulant many people historically
that have had lupus were discovered to
have actually also lupus
antiphospholipid antibody syndrome or
lupus anticoagulant present in their
blood but it doesn't mean that everybody
with those antibodies in their situation
that everybody has lupus anticoagulant
or or or other systemic disorders so it
can go both ways so antiphospholipid
antibody syndrome these slides will be
very explanatory it can be divided into
elastic primary and Inter secondary
primarily about 50 to 60% it's not
associated with any known condition so
it can come out of the blue while the
secondary antiphospholipid syndrome or
APs
it could be associated with systemic
lupus erythematosus HIV malignancies
drag associated for other conditions to
label somebody with ApS with
antiphospholipid syndrome that person
that unfortunate patient has to have
clinical evidence of thrombosis and
associated labs so positive labs because
at any point of time if we're testing
healthy individuals they can have some
circulating antiphospholipid antibodies
aka
lupus anticoagulant it doesn't mean that
they have antiphospholipid antibody
syndrome so in order to have the
syndrome who have to have clinical
evidence of trumbo sees and claps so
what you see on this slide it's the
international consensus statement of
revised criteria for classification of
the antiphospholipid syndrome it's known
as Sydney criteria from 2004 in 1999 a
preliminary set of ApS classification
criteria was established after the
workshop held in Sapporo Japan the main
contribution of the subsequent workshop
this is the slide that you are seeing
now Sydney 2004 was extensive review and
revision of the Sapporo criteria and
inclusion of antibodies against Bayer to
black protein 1 no new clinical
criterias were added but experts
highlighted signs and symptoms such as
trauma center Pina non thrombotic
central nervous system manifestations
such as cognitive dysfunction
liver the relief reticularis in the
property hemolytic anemia and cardiac
valve in
so this slide based on the city's
criteria is most likely not set in stone
and will change given the ongoing
efforts to fully elucidate the nature
and ever-evolving manifestations of this
disease process although the Sydney and
the city's ApS classification was not
initially designed for clinical purposes
only for research purposes they still
represent the best current tool to
prevent over diagnosis of ApS because
many conditions can lean towards easily
diagnosis ABS just because of something
that are present or there is some some
electrical apps present day there may be
able to quickly to jump the guns and to
label the person to diagnose a person
with aps but they stick with a current
diagnostic criteria clinical criteria
laboratory criteria then maybe where
there is a less chance of overdiagnosis
this condition currently keep in mind
that because of the recognized unique
and broad clinical manifestations of aps
the final diagnosis which will always
rely on the physician's judgment so if
physician strongly believes of peor
feels that that the patient needs the
criteria even though it doesn't strictly
fit with the pregnancy morbidity
criteria or vascular thrombosis criteria
that is laid on an underlay on this
slide they she can still be diagnosed
with lupus anticoagulant if appropriate
set of labs is there and some associated
clinical symptoms are present so I spent
some a long time on this slide but
because they gave me time to read so
clinical criteria vascular thrombosis or
and or pregnancy morbidity so one or
more unexpected deaths of our
biologically normal fetus at or beyond
the 10th week of gestation or one or
more Crematory birds are logically
normal neonate acts on before the 34th
week of gestation due to preeclampsia
eclampsia or placental insufficiency
three or more unexplained consecutive
spontaneous abortions before the 10th
week of gestation with maternal and
mechanic or with maternal anatomic or
hormonal abnormalities so this is
clinical and laboratory criteria anti
cardiolipin antibodies either IgG IgM
and anti beta 2 glycoprotein antibodies
either IgG IgM and we're gonna mention
later are the importance of the specific
tires to call it the coop to call
positive positive and negative negatives
because they have to be measured by
certain methods and they have to be
present at certain concentrations to
call them positive so so this is the
current set of criterias and it's called
the sidney's criteria and still as we
were speaking their workshops being held
so this criteria may be revised
but for now on this is kind of I would
say very good and reliable point of
reference in diagnosis antiphospholipid
antibody cetera so having said that if
you go to the next slide we're going to
the basics so phospholipids are present
everywhere they are only present
components of cellular membranes extra
intracellularly
there are the surface of the cell so
they're embedded we can see that there
is a phospholipid bilayer sandwiched
between the protease and surface
glycoproteins that always also serve as
receptors for many extracellular
molecules so phospholipids are not just
providing the cushion inside the cell
but they are their conformation it's
important in transmitting signal from
the from outside cell to inside the cell
all the way to the new clips so there
are many phospholipids there's a one I
mean we can we can spend probably a few
hours enumerated in phospholipids
prospecting they'll call a precipitous I
didn't see Ryan prospective ethanol
amine prospectively little cardio light
beam career light beam is by first
active deal by first active bill
glycerol then beta 2 glycoprotein
annexin make sure that you know that
when we're talking about phospholipids
some molecules are biochemically not
phospholipids but they are closely
interacting with phospholipid under
under surface under membrane of the cell
for example beta 2 glycoprotein we can
the maybe thousands glycoprotein so they
it has a sugar moiety and it has the
protein mighty but it's closely embedded
closely related to karyotyping so they
always go hand-in-hand then I'm mixing
it's not technically speaking and by
coming by chemically speaking it's not
phospholipid it's a protein but a next
thing is sandwich in middle portion of
the phospholipid membrane that is
preventing certain anionic part of
phospholipid molecule to flip over and
to go over and serves so the perfect
conformation of the cellular membrane
it's maintained through very fine very
delicate in interplay between
phospholipids and associated proteins
including beta 2 glycoprotein and Maxine
and other products
so we know that coagulation reactions
are occurring on cellular surfaces and
endothelial cell surface on plated
surface even and white blood cells when
they are activated and they interact
with endothelial cells like monocytes
polymorphonuclear all those cells have
phospholipids that fur that create a
perfect let's put it up let's be
romantic today to say a perfect cradle
in which coagulation factors reside they
are invited they interact with a
phospholipid surface and they activate
each other and execute well known
coagulation cascade or coagulation
reactions when the intrinsic pathway
extrinsic pathway and the common battery
we know that fortunately we're not
forming clots spontaneously so in the
healthy individual coagulation reactions
are not occurring spontaneously so that
was philippic membrane is somewhat
dormant so what ensures that coagulation
that phospholipids are not sticking out
to the surface of the cell in body
coagulation factors there are many
factors that contribute to that first of
all there is something phospholipid
compostable see right that is
physiologically cushioned in a middle
portion towards the bottom of the
phospholipid layer and it's kept there
because of beta 2 glycoprotein and next
things or other proteins that they are
keeping perfect bill serum and a bottom
of cellular membrane so this very
important phospholipid important in
terms of coagulation it's kept on a
bottom of the membrane in a dormant
endothelial service
but when initiated cladding reactions
are occurring and phospholipid to reach
cell members what does it mean
coagulation resins wretches to be
initiated so whether we had the injury
of endothelium which will cause the flip
of the phosphatidyl serine from the
inner to the outer part of the membrane
or we're gonna have different
interactions in the membrane or
antibodies will remove some part let's
say we have antiphospholipid antibodies
they can remove some parts of the
molecule from that dormant membrane and
help exposing health topics for society
build serum to the surface and there
ones on the surface for stability I can
concentrate coagulation factors through
its and ionic interactions with
coagulation factors and this can cause
formation of thrombin and subsequently
troubling is gonna call activate
polymerized fibrinogen into fibrin so we
know that we have extrinsic intrinsic
pathway this is a very conveniently made
division of two arms of the coagulation
pathway although in reality intrinsic
and extrinsic pattern of coagulation are
kind of talking to each other there is a
fine interplay between the intrinsic
intrinsic and reacts extrinsic pathway
but just for the sake of this slide and
for the sake of the broader audience
when they're trying to visualize
regulation reactions we we put them in a
separate in the intrinsic and the
extrinsic arm and the common pathway
which is called the prothrombin effect
where prothrombin is complex so the X
racing pathway it's called us also
extrinsic
Hemmings why because we have tissue
factor with the activist factor 7-inches
RNA
factor seven with the cofactor learn
connective a factor of 10 and factor 10
goes into the proton baby's arm which is
the common pathway and activate tractor
with a cofactor five can further
activate factor 10 into 10 a and factor
time I can activate proton beam to
crumby and tromping connecting for
bridging polymerase fabulous into fire
on the other side we have the intrinsic
10 days we have factor 8 and 9 factor 8
is a cofactor of a factor 9 is serine
protease so they interplay and the
phospholipid surface will activate
factor 10 converts turning to attend a
and then we have again we're going into
the common pathway where we create
thrombin and we create fibrin at the end
we formed a class but again when
initiated those reactions they have
something in common that they are
happening on the phospholipid surface
where first perspective in serum is
flipped from the bottom of the membrane
towards the surface of the membrane so
beta 2 glycoprotein unmixing and
cardiolipin what what is their role in
coagulation normal cell number because
if you remember the Diagnostics slide of
the sydney criteria we weren't for just
diagnosed somebody with better -
glycoprotein / with this unconscious I
will enter first ribbon either by the
syndrome we were those patients to have
beta glycoprotein antibody detected or
courier - antibody detected right so
what is the role of those molecules in
coagulation dormant cell membrane let's
say a mixing a mixing is a protein
Nexen is a protein that is sitting in
the middle of the membrane it's four
forms sort of a crystals but it's kind
of a this just crystal formation in a
part of the membrane that it's keeping
perspective in serum form from being
overexposed so next thing is in the P
layer protein in many tissues including
placenta remember but we talked about
miscarriages or pregnancy morbidity
we're gonna see that an axon is an
integral part of antiphospholipid
antibody sins are associated with
pregnancy morbidity so that's why I
Maxine something is happening with the
next thing in placenta when women are
having a spontaneous miscarriages do to
enter phospholipid antibodies cetera so
what is an axon doing physiologically in
our membranes
it has high affinity for anionic
phospholipids in the lamb enters it's
keeping them in a dormant shake
untouched and disturbed and Maxine it's
keeping phosphatidylserine in a dormant
shape or dormant state so it has also
capacity to displace coagulation factors
for from phospholipid services what
about beta 2 glycoprotein so beta 2 like
a protein is present in membrane and the
in circulation so it just member knows
glycoprotein its present in circulation
in life circulation because it's a
integral constituent of chylomicrons and
lipoproteins it prevents binding of
protein s to c4 be binding protein and
we know that protein s its anticoagulant
only if its present in circulation in
its free form so beta 2 glycoprotein
it's important in circulation because
it's preventing binding of pretty much
preventing in activation of protein s
then also beta 2 glycoprotein down
regulates activation of tagging
factor which is vector twelve which is
the first serine protease being
activated in the well-known X in the
whether intrinsic pathway because factor
12 activity activity level nine and
eight so this is part of the intrinsic
cascade inhibits tissue factor activity
also important because once we have a
tissue factor and interior surfaces
inactivation factor seven we have very
broad activation of the extrinsic
pathway so beta to black or protein is
preventing activation of the extrinsic
pathway as well then inhibits various
related functions is from this is
probably not well known role of beta 2
glycoprotein but baylor to a
glycoprotein that is also known as known
as april lipoprotein age has receptors
and platelets so receptors and platelets
are when they bind april plot prey april
like a protein age or data to like a
protein this interaction has net
inhibitory effect on platelets so free
beta 2 glycoprotein bound and platelets
is preventing adp our activation or
other agonists the model above modified
egg activation of platelets so platelets
are also maintained in in in a more
dormant non-activated states when we
have healthy levels are unaffected and
beta 2 glycoprotein under the pineal
surfaces and on a platelet service then
what is happening with korea lipping
some people say career lipping some
researchers are calling it karyotyping
so let's stick with carrier lipid
to this presentation so what is carrier
Lippe
it's a major phospholipid on
mitochondria mitochondrial membrane
it's crucial for mitochondrial function
and cellular processes outside of the
mitochondria so we also know that it's
important courier are living in
apoptosis cascade since it's part of the
inner mitochondrial membrane with
cytochrome C oxidase and cardiolipin
it's facilitating the release and
activation of a pathetic molecules once
the cell is damaged so it's facilitating
cell death of programmed cell death or
apoptosis so you can see that also there
is a kind of potential if cardiolipin
it's not maintaining its function
properly that the cell can either start
dying or previously healthy cell can
start exposing before a phospholipid
sonic service and activist coagulation
cascade which will eventually lead to
the formation of turbos so that's why
cardiolipin it's not just embedded in a
mitochondria it's also a matter Konya
member it's present in different parts
of cellular membranes including surface
membrane so historically literature was
emphasizing its role in mitochondrial
function but career lipid there is no
research show that carnitine is present
not just in mitochondrial membrane it's
also present in epithelial surface
membrane and other cell members so this
slide I included important molecules I
tried to emphasize their physiological
role and to give you a hint to my
audience to give you a hint
something is wrong with these molecules
if they are not positioned properly if
they are activated if they are removed
from their original position in the cell
membrane then we have a potential of
formation of activation or coagulation
cascade information of thrown by so all
these molecules their intricate 2
linkage among themselves within the
membrane prevents assembly of
coagulation factors of the cellular
service so that's why they are important
so this slides now after me spending too
much time elaborating physiological role
of certain molecules and physiology
physiology of coagulation cascade then
you should already know what are the
enemies of spontaneous clinic so the
most common enemies the the big groups
of factors that prevent spontaneous
formation of class are healthy and the
feeling with dormant phospholipid
surfaces including functional and Xing
beta 2 glycoprotein Korea lipid then
production of this or dilators and
plated inhibitors such as nitric oxide
process I clean production of pro
fibrinolytic factors such as tissue
plasminogen activators expression of
thrombomodulin which interacts with
anticoagulant protein CNS because once
the turbine is formed it binds frumble
module and thrombomodulin will activate
would create a good amounts of activated
protein C which is anticoagulant
so healthy endothelium their balance of
coagulation factors and anticoagulant
proteins and good blood flow so these
are all enemies the quotes of
spontaneous firing
so antiphospholipid antibodies they can
affect cold and quiet and ethereal
service and are important are important
for two reasons they can be confusing
because if their presence and if
clinicians are ordering common commonly
perform the most commonly perform
calculations tests like PTT or PT or
other tests for namely PTT those
antibodies are those are give those
molecules can prolong planning times
prolong the clock bed based assays like
a PTT so this is happening in vitro but
in vivo they promote term BOCES so this
is a paradox because we always expect
when something is prolonging the PTT
then that factor in circulation will
cause bleeding no with antiphospholipid
antibodies they we have different
difference between in vitro tests that
will be prolonged and in vivo situation
in in a body that can they can actually
wreak havoc they can cause spontaneous
formation of antibodies and they lead to
very significant and the phospholipid
antibodies associated morbidity and
unfortunately mortality which is we want
to prevent by properly diagnostic and
the phospholipid antibodies diagnose
against the phospholipid syndrome and
the possibly enter antibody syndrome and
initiating timely and the most
appropriate and acquire urine therapy
so slides 14 that you have in front of
you this rather busy slide
maybe this slide illustrates the full
complexity of in vivo activation event
the phospholipid antibodies and since
they bind not just to phospholipids but
also to embedded proteins such as total
B which may facilitate generation of
thrombin which is a pivotal step in
coagulation than to anticoagulant
protein C and s or to an Xing for
example thereby enabling the
phosphatidylserine
flip on a membrane and amplification of
the coagulation reactions so antibodies
can bind beta 2 glycoprotein they can
remove that in gaming that I like to use
the alignment terms because I believe
that this is the most useful for the
audience because then you're gonna
understand and you're gonna always
remember the role of certain molecules
in their pathophysiological wrong so I
would say the beta 2 glycoprotein
prevents a smooth and ethereal cell
coverage or than the to your service the
moment we have the antibodies that
they're affecting beta 2 glycoprotein
confirmation they can uplift that
antibody and they perturbed the
previously dormant cell service and they
were having exposure or other
phospholipids and activation or
coagulation reactions so there are
different mechanisms but once we have
binding of those antibodies to
endothelium
we can activate we can over express
phospholipids on a surface the we can
cause and the thelia cell activation
subsequently you can have inflammation
cascade with the T cell immune response
activate a generation of a lot of
for inflammatory cytokines and they're
simply like too many pathways converging
on each other towards the formation of
that class and then you have the
formation occlusion of the vessel and
you have the antiphospholipid syndrome
so one of the proposed models for
cladding or tissue injury within type
beta 2 glycoprotein antibodies also that
antibodies can dimerize
beta 2 glycoprotein and cell a membrane
we say that beta took like a protein on
cell membrane which is known as a April
like a protein age it's present in the
failure surface a plated surface so once
that molecule it's dimerize by the
binding of antibody that binds that
molecule then we know that formation
that any antibody being bound to an
antigen can activate the complement
cascade activated complement can further
activate our monocytes can activate
platelets then with a generation of
let's say from monocyte the tumor
necrosis factor we have tissue damage
Peter are people that think it's
happening in the placenta thrombosis so
you have depending on which organ this
is happening you have associated
pathology of that organ whether it's
vessel vasculature heart kidneys
placenta with the pregnancy morbidity so
they are simply we can spend all day
talking about once you activate the
coagulation cascade the complement
pathway then we have many mechanisms of
the tissue injury so gonna slide 16 the
this five may well exemplified the role
of connect seen so we talked about beta
to like a protein now let's talk about
the next thing in pathogenesis of
antiphospholipid syndrome and you will
remember
pregnancy morbidity is one of the
criteria in the Sydney classification of
the APS so this reaction this research
from 1997 it furnishes the link between
antibodies again our next thing and the
pregnancy loss because i'm maxeen it's
it's present as a molecule as a protein
on the surface of the cells and in a
trophoblast
if it's present in it's a physiological
position then it's presenting a parent
information of class reduce the Nexen
levels in a factual vascular cells let's
say due to antibodies that can uplift
and remove the election may be an
important mechanism of the bosses and
pregnancy loss in antiphospholipid
antibody syndrome here i wrote at
antiphospholipid antibody serum it could
be a PS or a PLA so I'm also using
different terms just to familiarize you
and for you to be used when you are
reading something about the APS to know
not to be confused there are many names
for the same entity for the same same
surgery I'm gonna flip to the next slide
cardiolipin you remember that it's one
of the criteria for detection of
antiphospholipid syndrome cardiolipin
and anti carrier lip identifiers so
there is evidence that anti carrier
lipping antibodies bind to phospholipid
epitopes and platelet membrane this
concept is kind of maybe a little more
difficult to grasp conceptually again
because historically we're talking about
cardio leaping present and only
mitochondria then you're gonna ask
yourself from whatever mitochondria's
have to do with clay tracks and the
circles how is the club being formed so
cardiolipin was starts to be present
mitochondria but there is evidence that
this phospholipid is reacting with
membranous molecules including better
Blanco protein 1 so cardiolipin is
interacting with beta 2 black or protein
1 and cell surfaces so if something is
happening with the glycoprotein with
beta 2 like a protein it can well our
interview with courier lipid so
antibodies against cardiolipin can
interact with beta 2 black a protein
that's why there is a very fine
interplay between these two molecules
and they're often inextricable from each
other
and even in your testing you're gonna
see that often the sensitivity and
specificity of testing for
antiphospholipid antibody syndrome where
both antibodies are detected for again
scarring a lipid and against beta 2
glycoprotein then we have a greater
chance that the patient is truly having
antiphospholipid antibody syndrome
because these are not just any
antibodies those are really antibodies
that can bind both molecules cardio
lipid and better to like a protein and
those are the antibodies that really
have the potential to - to initiate
coagulation reaction on between yourself
surface so it's important to remember
that cardio leaping and correlating
antibodies that those antibodies are
those epitope scarlatina pickups they
are not only present somewhere inside
mitochondria they can be present and at
the fuel cell surface and the platelets
sirs why is this important because if
the factors and the cardiolipin
antibodies then we're gonna label the
patient that this patient has anti
cardiolipin antibody syndrome or ACA so
ACA will be diagnosed when anti
cardiolipin antibodies are detected and
this saver will show you that they are
having some clinical differences between
anti cardiolipin entire
and the claim simple the Croats lupus
anticoagulant why because antic
re-electing antibodies they can often
cause our period on bosses while you see
that lupus anticoagulant are simple and
that was so lipid antibodies that they
do not have specificity against carrier
lipid they often do not cause our Kirito
bosses they form venous thrombosis
so why because aunt Akari alipin
antibodies can attack platelets they can
by career leaping and platelets activate
platelets in your informational class
and arterial side of the vessel where
blood flow is usually more brisk so it's
more difficult to form class and their
arterial side of the vessel but once you
have a clock under arterial side of the
vessel then probably tells you that
platelets are activator so anti
cardiolipin antibodies have their
potential to form clots and the arterial
side of the vessel because of activation
of platelets while the planes simple the
rest of lupus anticoagulants they often
do not form arterial class before venous
clots like DVT pulmonary embolism etc
but again they are not commonly
associated with arterial thrombosis
going to the next slide how do we give
names to enter possibility that you
heard know too many molecules being
mentioned and they can all be put in the
waste kind of basket of antiphospholipid
antibodies
yes we can say that whether you have
antiphospholipid antibody or anti
which includes that cardiolipin
antibodies or anti let's say
phosphatidylserine antibody or either or
other bodies these are all
antiphospholipid antibodies but
sometimes we can be a little more
specific and give it a name to that
antibody so if we're able
to determine the specificity of antibody
antigen binding and to know exactly
against which phospholipid antibodies
directed then we can give it a more
specific name to death antiphospholipid
antibody if not then we're gonna just
call antiphospholipid antibody or
antiphospholipid antibody or lupus
anticoagulant is detected but we are not
able to give a give it a more specific
name so so it depends how I detect them
and what they are what those antibodies
are directed against those detected by
the cloud based assays or indirect
essays that we will talk about are
commonly nose and lupus anticoagulant or
just temper phospholipid antibodies
we're going to talk about testing or
antiphospholipid antibodies soon and
you're gonna see that we have indirect
and the direct assess indirect assays
are unable to specify the antibody or
the phospholipid being affected so
that's why if we detect that went across
the lipid antibodies present in the
indirect who via the food in the
indirect methods we gonna easily say
that antiphospholipid antibody lupus
anticoagulant is detected but if we're
having specific methods like direct
methods so there are different methods
like direct methods using a Lezama up or
chemiluminescent methods then we're
gonna be able to pick up some specific
antibodies against cardiolipin for
example and they were gonna say that the
patient has Carly and I carry a lipid
antibody sensor which is
antiphospholipid antibody syndrome we
can be more specific and say
anti carrier lipid and the gara cetera
so what are the methods for detection of
antiphospholipid antibodies aka lupus
anticoagulant
we're indirect and direct so indirect
methods are silica cladding time the
most commonly used silica cladding tiles
for the PTT
because we use the silica as the contact
activator to initiate the intrinsic
coagulation pathway via the activation
of coagulation factor twelve eleven ten
nine eight and they were going to the
common pathway we also have dilute
russell viper venom time i don't know if
you heard the the acronym dr v VT so
this is the lewis russell my product i'm
then we have Carol incurring time where
we're using Calvin instead of silica in
order to initiate clotting in the
intrinsic pathway so these are the
indirect methods so they're also known
as collateral assets why collateral
because we are initiating the cladding
creation reaction and the form which
eventually result in the formation of a
clot in a tooth so based on a time that
it takes to form the class based on a
length of time in seconds we can
determine if the cladding time is normal
or its prolonged and if it's for logged
then we're gonna be able during who
using our diagnostic methods to
determine why is it prolonged is it
because of some factor deficiencies in
the conic pathways or it's because of
some inhibitors and antiphospholipid
antibodies are inhibitors of the
cladding reactions in vitro in a tool
and that's why we call those s i--'s
collateral assays so we're gonna spend a
little more time explaining indirect SS
so they work through the effect and
possibility dependent coagulation asses
so the principles and the phospholipid
antibodies can affect the phospholipid
used in some laboratory tests we know
that so we know that we are using silica
to activate intrinsic that way you are
using calcium to run the aPTT
you're adding phospholipids but you
simply if you have antiphospholipid
antibodies present in patient serum they
can interact with with the reagent and
if they are reacting with the reagent
this can prolong the clotting time
so the protocol time can be prolonged so
demonstration of the presence of them
and the phospholipid antibody by
coagulation test requires propagation of
a phospholipid dependent coagulation
tests like a PTT and this end is
important and collection of the
prolongation by adding an excess of
phospholipid or otherwise eliminating
the effect of any
antiphospholipid antibodies or APL so we
have to document that that initial
prolongation of the cutting time was
indeed happened or caused by
antiphospholipid antibodies and we're
going to prove that by how by adding
extra phospholipid in a in a in patient
plasma and we rerun the test and in the
cutting time shortens then we're gonna
infer that initially prolonged and the
forcefully pro rata blessing was due to
antiphospholipid entities so were
clipping to the slide 22 just to
remember always the clotting cascade
pathways whether it's
PTT testing the intrinsic pathway or the
PTX tracing testing the extrinsic
pathway these are all heavily dependent
on phospholipids
intrinsic pathway the extrinsic pathway
they both converge towards the common
pathway common pathway it's also known
as the proper on beliefs that way the
common pathway and I'm adding in this
slide plpl so I'm going the previous
slide sorry so you see that all these
steps conversion effector nine to nine a
conversion of ten to ten a conversion of
protein or beta proton beam this all
steps require phospholipids because all
those reactions are occurring and
phospholipid rich serves so that's why
we cannot initiate coagulation our
reactions in vitro in a tube unless we
have phospholipid reagent edit whether
it's we're testing the intrinsic pathway
apt T or the P P so this slide is a
little more busy and you're gonna see
some names like KCT and apt D so this is
calling climbing time and PTT so these
are different versions of activation of
tested active and that actually
activates the intrinsic the longer
pathway that presents the results in the
formation of hybrid through the
activation of factor 12 high molecular
weight continue J so this is the contact
activation pathway and then we're
converging towards 1010 a together with
a find a patron prothrombin to thrombin
something it's converting to a villager
into five right and we have the DDT
which is the dilute proton beam time so
we can test the phospholipid dependent
pathways by testing the extrinsic
pathway so this is called a neutron big
time
so we wanna see if the entry
our present I guess phospholipids they
will increase the dilute rot from being
died they will increase that diluted
version of prothrombin time or the PT
and we're gonna say why did they lose
version I'm gonna explain why is the
newer version of PT or diluted version
of a PTT where we're testing and the
phospholipid Enterprise so both pathways
are converging into the common pathway
and the common pathway we have one test
that is called DRA VT they are ready
please dilute Russell my pro bono test
that can cause that can determine the
role of phospholipids and
antiphospholipid antibodies are present
in patient serum dilute Russell Russell
bipropellant
test will be able to document that
antiphospholipid antibodies are
interfering with the common pathway
which is the pathway that involves
conversion of 10 into 10 a and 10 they
will eventually activate predominant
attorney and we gonna generate the cart
ride the the common pathway so this was
the slide 23 some major indirect methods
major so I talked about dilutes proton
beam time carolling time a PTT we are
riveted but remember in the commercial
labs in the hospital labs and I work in
the hospital back to I would say nine
out of ten or 19 out of 20 hasta
collapse will not use all possible
clarabelle assays to detect the present
equivalent or antiphospholipid
antibodies using the intrinsic pathway
or the camel pathway they gonna use only
two of those that I explained a PTT
which is act
the partial thromboplastin time and
their dependence on phospholipids and
dilute Russell's Viper random time which
is the ability
so both SS we call them diluting
beginning why dilute wines dilute
Russell viper venom test different from
let's say an undiluted Russell Viper a
notice or wise diluted a PTT or known as
lupus anticoagulant sensitive a PTT why
is this diluted a PTT
instead of the regular a PTT simply
because if we had lower concentrations
of it the phospholipid antibodies in
patients plasma we draw the blood from
the patient we have the whole blood we
can explain it down then we want to
perform the PTT if we have lower amount
of antibodies and we wanna run the
regular PTT or regular Russell viper
venom test those weak antiphospholipid
antibodies will not be able to interfere
with our phospholipid reagents that we
are adding in a tube but we if we add
the unit version of that phospholipids
then even smaller amounts of
antiphospholipid antibodies will
interfere with the reagent so that's why
lupus anticoagulant being tested by PTT
we're actually using diluted version of
a PTT which is using lower concentration
of phospholipid as a reagent and it's
called lupus sensitive PDT or a light
sensitive PGP or the loaded a PTT
Russell viper venom test on the other
hand which is testing the
come a bath way it's using diluted
Russell viper venom so it's diluted
version of phospholipid that we're
adding in patients plasma and when we
add that Russell reagent which is pretty
much a snake venom that is supposed to
form clots if we have antiphospholipid
antibodies present in the serum they can
interfere with the they wouldn't
phospholipid in which we use as a
reagent and then the ability is going to
be prolonged so with using diluted
version of cutting test reagents we are
increasing the sensitivity of the test
we're increasing the probability that
we're gonna detect antiphospholipid
antibodies being present in patients
here and flipping over to the next slide
which is slide 25 so the current
classification for laboratory diagnosis
were being revised so so how we
determine the positive la lupus
anticoagulant or antiphospholipid
antibody via the PTT platform so
positive or la means that we have a
clotting time with low phospholipid
concentration which is again lupus
sensitive PTT so that time in seconds -
clotting time of the same plasma when we
add the higher concentration of
phospholipid what is the high
concentration of phospholipids so we can
add extra phospholipid in a form of
hexagonal s a hexagonal phospholipids
so these are usually plant extracted or
animal source extracted so this is you
with high concentration of phospholipid
so we wanna test plasma let's say PTT
with the low concentration of
phospholipid we have the time in seconds
how quickly it takes to form the clock
in seconds and we write it out then we
take the patient's plasma we add extra
phospholipid and see how long it takes
to form the clutch using extra
phospholipid that difference it's
significant
the higher the difference between those
two cladding times the greater the
chance that we have antiphospholipid
antibody pressed so positive for lupus
anticoagulant determination it depends
on the difference between clotting time
with lock phospholipid concentration
minus cladding time with hypersonic
concentration we can determine by inter
laboratory study or inter-institutional
or inter-institutional studies we can
determine what is the significant time
difference in seconds that we can say
hey the difference in the cladding time
was due to at the cross Philippi for
example in our lab is 11 seconds or you
can calculate that correction
how much do you correct cleaning time or
how much do you sure to the clotting
time if you add extra phospholipids as a
reagent in a testing tool so we can
either determine positive lupus
anticoagulant by determining the
difference between clotting times or
percentage of correction which is
clotting time with low concentration
phospholipid - clotting time with high
concentration phospholipids
so this is in your numerator and in the
denominator you have cladding time with
low phospholipid concentration so this
is usually that that high cladding time
and then this times 100 and that
percentage percent of correction can be
used to determine the presence like the
body or normalized ratio screen ratio
over configuration so don't get anxious
I'm going to explain to you how we
calculate positive tests at UIC for
example where I work
how do we determine that let's say using
DRV VT which is testing the
phospholipids in the camel pathway how
how do we determine the DRI VT it's
positive and the release in do caused by
antiphospholipid antibodies I'm gonna
show you this so what is the principle
of derivative so this is right for
Russell why Russell's bipropellant
which directly activates factor 5 a
factor 10 in the presence of
phospholipid and calcium is bypassing
factor 7 of the extrinsic extrinsic
pepper so it means that we directly
activate factor 10 together with the
cofactor 5 when we put snake venom in
patients plasma so in normal Plaza in
the absence of lupus anticoagulant or
antiphospholipid antibodies vector v and
factor 10 they are directly activated by
by the snake manner in the class it's
quickly being formed so in the presence
of the phospholipid reagents and the
calcium that we add the the class will
be formed however if it's prolonged if
then the aridity
is prolonged then we have to determine
what is causing propagate propagation of
that that test
we have to take patients plasma and to
mix with normal poo poo class because
normal plasma has all concentration
factors inside and if we correct the
initially from clotting time then we
could have treated the initial
promulgation of the heredity or ptg
depending on which tests were using we
gonna treated this to factor deficiency
so we're gonna say that the mixing
corrected the clotting time and we do
not have lupus anticoagulant suspected
and the initially prolonged test was due
to factor deficiency however if the MIS
mixing does not correct
dr DVT or dilute version of PTT or also
known as lupus sensitive PTT if the
mixing between patients and or no plasma
does not correct that time then we have
to do the confirmation so how do we how
do we do the confirmation we add extra
phospholipids in patients plasma and we
simply repeat a test and if it corrects
then we're gonna say it's positive for
lupus anticoagulants
if it does not correct if it does not
sufficiently shorter the clotting time
after the phosphor reach phospholipid
source has been have been added and then
we're gonna say that lupus anticoagulant
all right that was Philippi the
antibodies I am NOT at that so this is
the kind of the commonly use in hospital
labs diagram or algorithm diagnostic
algorithm for determination around the
phospholipid a device
so again this is simply a flow work how
workflow how it goes
not flow work in the projects flow work
probably didn't sleep good last night
so collection of blood samples so we
double centrifuge the sample we have to
make sure that we have a platelet poor
plasma that we eliminate platelets as a
source we wanna have as fewer plasma in
the patient sample as possible okay then
we use two tests that's why the it's
important for them to be ordered
together the Nuge version of PTT or Lu
processes the PTT and dilute Russell
Viper a no dust
we simply perform the test and we see if
it's prolonged then we're gonna do the
mixing test 1:1 mixed if it's not
prolonged then we'll do confirmatory
tests by having extra phospholipids and
we if it's correcting meaning if it's
official sufficiently short is declaring
time after phospholipids are being used
then we can diagnose the patient's
plasma as being positive for
antiphospholipid antibodies or being
positive for lupus anticoagulant so this
is what i promised to you how we report
it at UIC so maybe this slide will
explain really it's gonna simplify
everything that i mentioned before
so let's say driv t so they are really t
we do first the screen ratio this is
what we report which means patient
dilute Russell's Viner of a viper venom
test in seconds over dilute Russell
Viper ran a test of pool normal plasma
so we simply make platelet pool plasma
patient and they are ready theory they
are relatively agent which is diluted
phospholipids reagent with
the snake venom that contains deluded
phospholipid and snake rattle and
calcium so once we add this and test we
gonna remember or our system will
remember this is the patient we are
deleting sense if it's prolongs then
we're gonna do mixing if it does not go
along with mixing then we will take
patients plasma and extra phospholipids
and run really BP with extra
phospholipids then our system will
remember patients initially our EVP and
actually x-axis phospholipid ability
so all those glaring times our system
remembers so if initial screen raesha so
this is important what was screen ratio
patient derivative over the aridity of
two normal plasma if it was increased or
greater than 1.25 in our lab we perform
mix if mix does not correct meaning it's
still that mix plasma mixed plasma the
ability of the mixed plasma over the
derivative pool classmates still greater
than 1/4 it's about 1.45 it means that
we probably have some inhibition some
inhibitor in class because the mixing
did not correct the derivative then as I
mentioned before then we have that
patient theory with peak with extra
phospholipid we remember the time in
seconds and we have played the turn or
plasma with extra phospholipid and we
have that time in seconds so now we do
their best ratio between patient
with phospholipids over normal plasma
phospholipids better Asia
it's called confirm ratio so if patience
dilutes right Russell hypervenom time
initial time with extra phospholipid
sufficiently decreases shortens because
we're having extra phospholipid then of
course that this numerator it's going to
be some low time in seconds some smaller
number in seconds while the plate Adama
plasma which phospholipids will stay
probably the same because nothing will
happen with normal pool plasma when
we're adding extra phospholipids so that
time in seconds we say the same so
confirm ratio we expect usually that
number the treasure to be low if the
patient truly has antiphospholipid
antibodies because extra phospholipid
will shorten the aridity so that ratio
patient already over normal the aridity
with the extra phospholipid but cannot
be lower number so confirm ratio it's
usually consistent remembers our
computer system remembers that that
ratio and final result how we report is
normalize ratio so we report the
normalize ratio which is the screen
ratio over the confirm ratio screen
ratio is a big number in seconds right
because what was the screen ratio
patient liability over normal pool
plasma derivative so patient they are
ready t if it had prolonged clotting
time because of and the phospholipids
was a high number so screen ratio is
always big number one confirm ratio as
we explained in a previous bullet was a
low number if antiphospholipid
antibodies oppressed so simply
screen ratio over confirm ratio in our
lab if it's equal or greater
and 1.25 then we were gonna report it as
positive palooka center for follicular
positive on lupus anticoagulant or the
test is positive or antiphospholipid
antibodies so this is our labs principle
for the determination of
antiphospholipid antibodies
okay lupus anticoagulant so I spent some
time I'm hoping I didn't confuse you
with the explanation of indirect methods
it was rather a winded explanation but I
was trying to be graphic often to
explain to you so you remember the
principle of indirect us which are
important because we have to have both
either direct or in we have to use all
possible tests in order to determine the
presence of antibodies why because if we
have strong clinical suspicion based on
the clinical criteria we want to make
sure that we have good tests to detect
the presence of antibodies in patients
here whether we are using indirect
methods whether a PTT or derivative or
direct records that I'm gonna mention on
this slide so current classifications
and laboratory diagnosis even now being
revised so in to do you remember that
the city criteria was done in 2004 in
2009 there was scientific Subcommittee
on standardization a lupus anticoagulant
and antiphospholipid antibodies of the
International Society of Composers and
hemostasis
they issued recommendation for
standardizations
of lupus testing by a PTT and the array
VT and all the stuff that I explained to
you five minutes ago
so those tests using the newer version
of phospholipid antibodies then confirm
battery steps by having extra
phospholipid mixing studies to make sure
that this is the initial prolongation
was not due to flexure deficiencies that
indeed was due to at the phospholipid
antibodies all those methods are being
revised and approved and recommended by
the International Society of thrombosis
and hemostasis so as we speak these
criteria are being revised improved and
maybe in the near future we're gonna
have like a new set of laboratory kind
of criteria for determination of
antiphospholipid antibodies so I'm
getting closer to finishing this
presentation laboratory criteria direct
methods we didn't talk about the direct
methods we spend too much time on the
indirect but direct methods are
conceptually easier to understand
because we simply have to have patients
plasma we have to have wells coated with
certain phospholipids career leap in
better to glycoproteins so these are
either
iliza plates so using iliza methods or
chemiluminescent methods so we already
know which phospholipids are used to
coat the well of the testing place then
we add patients plasma so the antibodies
are present in a patient's plasma during
the using different detection methods
and antibody amplification of signal we
can pick up this antibody antigen
reaction and we can specifically tell if
the antibodies detected against certain
antigens there isn't that well so that
way we can give it a name to the
antibody then we're gonna say anti beta
2 glycoprotein antibody is detected or
anti carrier liquid antibodies detected
or anti farsighted in ceará
antibody is being detected or anti first
attribute anonyme antibodies being
detected
so I'm measuring different antibodies
but currently in the testing algorithm
beta 2 glycoprotein and courier lipping
are part of the classification criteria
while there are many more antibodies
that can be tested and maybe they gonna
be included in the laboratory diagnostic
criteria for for determination of
antiphospholipid antibody syndrome in
the future in the near future mention on
this slide that now the current methods
are using detection of either IgM or IgG
against both molecule and they have to
be presented as a certain title either a
4e a glycoprotein units or courier lipid
units or greater than 99% percent off
for either anti carry lipid or anti beta
took like a protein well okay so it's
important which target are we using
which Tyler is antibodies being detected
which concentration antibody and also
isotype we said IgG IgM but currently
it's worth mentioning that iga as iso
types are not included currently the
routine testing for antipas philippe
it's an embarrassing but there are more
prevalent in certain ethnic groups so
therefore some authors suggest that iga
anti beta took like a protein and iga
anti cardiolipin should be tested when
IG n or IgG isotypes are negative and we
still have the strong suspicion for for
antiphospholipid antibodies so currently
iga is not included but it may be
included in a future diagnostic
criteria so I would probably remember
that in testing all antibodies can be
tested which I enumerate it many other
antibodies that can be tested and they
are not included in a criteria so these
are those extra criteria and the planets
now the question is are you gonna is
your lab going to spend a lot of money
testing for anti was using less like
direct methods are using Eliza Eliza
that you got a test for anti prospective
bill glycerol and they first have to be
like an ala mean if you don't have to
probably not but if your clinician is
telling you that he or she has the
strong clinical suspicion for
antiphospholipid antibody syndrome and
that anything better to do like a
protein was negative event I carry a
liquid was negative then probably you
would like I'm assuming that you don't
have those tests in your lab you would
like to take the classmen to send out to
a reference lab some reference lab to
detect the presence over maybe other and
that was selected antibodies because
remember eventually it's dead clinicians
it's at his or her discretion whether
anti possibility that the Barre syndrome
will be will be diagnosed so doesn't
matter which antibody is positive if the
physician CLIA feels strongly that the
clinical criterias are there and he
believes strongly that clear criteria
and any of the antibodies is being
detected
then his has strong basis of the
diagnosing the patient for
antiphospholipid antibody cetera so
after you're gonna see that those
classical
criteria semi criteria I'm not
but still antiphospholipid antibody
syndrome can be diagnosed so there are a
lot of antibodies that can be casted
correct so what about the proteomic if
the protein is protein is not
phospholipid but programming is crucial
serine protease that by corrosion or
proteomic pro-trump before the class
performing is present and memory correct
so sometimes antiproton beam antibody
that I that also lipid antibodies they
can react I guess not from B so we have
a test sometimes that s not throbbing
and phospholipid complex or proton beam
and phosphate a building complex so
there are many many reference labs that
are using kits and either kids that they
are testing antiproton beam antibodies
or even anti an extra entry by
maintained at the virus or internal
demands so whichever is positive then
this is kind of strengthening the case
of that clinician in in in in diagnosing
the patient with antiphospholipid
antibody syndrome so this slide is
showing the body with many systemic
manifestations of antiphospholipid
antibody syndrome many sites the
locations were thrombi can for some like
Ascenta we already talked about or DVT
or other organs kidneys they can all be
affected but there are some locations
here body sites that initially the
previously will not thought to be
affected with antiphospholipid
antibodies now these are called extra
criteria for extra criteria clinical
manifestations or enter and the
phospholipid antibodies
so many different organs and as we speak
there they're being discovered that they
can be affected by antiphospholipid
antibody syndrome because remember clots
can pull in many organs in many organ
systems so a new extra criterias can
improve the accuracy of diagnosis so
remember that for patients suspected of
antiphospholipid antibody syndrome
between January and September 2013 if I
remember the antiphospholipid antibodies
task force and clinical manifestations
perform the review of the quality of
evidence which stem from low quality
evidence for clinical manifestations
like superficial trombonist or
thrombocytopenia or migraines or
migraines for example or other these are
kind of low criterias but we have some
criterias that are initially that were
not initially part of the diagnostic
tool from the clinical criteria but they
have kind of moderate or strong strength
of evidence that they are in creating
bit contributing to evolve in
antiphospholipid antibody seizure so for
example these are called moderate or
high quality of APL like a peer or
antiphospholipid antibody nephropathy or
valvular heart disease or libido
reticularis or longitudinal myelitis in
central nervous system so it is likely
that those new extra clinical criteria
will be added to the to the standard
criterion future so it's very likely
that the revisions of the signe criteria
are on the horizon
when it can happen very soon because as
this is very dynamic field more
antibodies are being detected more
phospholipid being attacked and affected
by antibodies are being detected so it's
just matter of standardizing those
antibodies detecting them and doing may
be a study that will really increase the
strength of evidence and then eventually
the committee will meet their new
criterias new criterias will be revised
so we're gonna have certainly more more
and more clinical manifestations that
should raise the awareness
hey maybe antiphospholipid antibodies is
happening in this patient or maybe the
station has the phospholipid antibodies
not just to attribute those
manifestations to lupus or connective
tissues diseases or other systemic
diseases because I would say that
antiphospholipid antibodies because of
the limitations of the criterias before
was under diagnosed and now with more
diagnostic criteria being included in
the list and the revisions of the list
maybe this test will be properly
diagnosed and it's very important for
clinicians to have the heightened
awareness of this syndrome
antiphospholipid antibody syndromes and
to know simply which tests to order so
their communication with the lab is a
session some lab and clinicians they
work to the other to diagnose
antiphospholipid antibody cetera so
there is an ongoing discussion between
classification versus diagnostic
criteria and as a national revisions are
on the horizon so this concludes my
presentation I hope I didn't confuse you
because I was very enthusiastic
trying to explain many things in a
relatively
short period of time so I'm open for
questions comments suggestions I would
like to thank dr. vadhana Veche for his
presentation I would also like to thank
labyrinth for making today's educational
webcast possible as a reminder our
speaker will follow up with your
questions via email if you have any
questions you'd like to ask just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left to your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on the screen
and click the send button before we go I
want to let everyone know that today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through December of 2018 you
will receive an email from laberd's
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's event that's
all for now thank you for joining us and
we hope to see you again soon goodbye